I hear that we're going to be using its
x-cubed plus or minus y cubed equals x
plus or minus y x squared minus or plus
XY plus y squared so what I've done is
I've combined the two formulas together
just to help cut down the memorization
for you but what you can see is if
you're adding two perfect cubes you're
gonna add subtract and then add if
you're subtracting you're gonna subtract
add and add a lot of students will
remember this easier using this acronym
same opposite always positive so you can
see it soap so it's the same so if
you're adding you add if you subtract
you subtract opposite so if you're
adding you subtract subtract you add and
then the last one you're always adding
so it's always positive so let's take a
look at some examples so say we're
factoring X cubed plus 8 so X cubed is
really like X cubed + 8 is really like 2
cubed so in our formula exes x + 2 is
our y-value okay so if we factor this is
going to be x + 2 x squared - 2 x + 2
squared which is 4 so you can see X + x2
+ 2 we're adding so we add opposite we
subtract last when we add and you can
see this is x squared okay the first
term squared the last term squared is 4
and the middle term we get by
multiplying the first and the last
together so the first and second term
together okay let's look at another
example so 27 C cubed minus 64 G cubed
so what I would do is I would take the
cube root of this so that's 3 see the
quantity cubed so I just wrote it as a
perfect cube and 64 d cubed is 4 d cubed
so in our formula this is the x value
and this is the Y value so all I'm going
to do is I'm just going to substitute
into this formula here we're subtracting
so
three c minus four D times three C
squared which is nine C squared plus
Kasim opposite we're going to multiply
these two together so that's 12 C D
always positive for the last one for D
the quantity squared which is 16 d
squared now if you want to see your
answer you can always distribute okay
and simplify and you'll get back to the
original so this is how to work with sum
of two cubes and difference of two cubes
I'll see you in the next video